I got to ask Fred about this many fans
wrote in about Fred and his new music
Venture I guess a lot of our fans follow
Fred on Instagram uh Hey Howard did you
check out Fred's new Instagram video he
wrote a song to accompany his friend's
pet bird named Echo he does not get
enough credit for being a musical genius
well no offense to friend I actually no
evidence I've asked Fred to write a hit
song for me no I haven't
I don't I mean a genius so here is Fred
it's weird it's a um it's to a bird or
for a bird what kind of bird is that
Fred what is it a uh parrot that's an
African gray parrot what is the noise
like it's like a it's doing a whistle
noise and then it's doing a chant now uh
the best story is the one that you just
invented which is you know I'm
collaborating with a parrot but if truth
be told I'm collaborating with the
parrots owner and the collaborator has
that parody the parent sits in the room
and it mimics just about everything and
it heard this song and heard the song
has whistling in it and a chant and the
bird liked it and was very inspired him
to decide to uh duplicate it
here's Fred Fred with a parrot
great bird it reminds me of uh the
member of that band the metal band that
recorded with the dog that's what I was
thinking canine is yeah Fred ripping off
canine is now working with
I actually thought this was really good
friend to be honest with you I think
you're on to something
[Music]
see that's the bird solo yeah yeah
and at the end if you hear that where he
says good boy boo boo he's complimenting
himself well oh wow you gotta love a
bird
they cut out the part where they said
get me away from Fred the Paris who's
screaming now we've never met face to
face but I'm looking forward to it all
right there he is Fred and bird funkle a
lot of people following Fred on
Instagram
foreign